looks like Joe Biden's running for
president that's a big here who might be
the front-runner right away yeah yeah
he's a lot of people think he's gonna be
the front-runner right away just by
entering the race and this is
interesting when asked about Joe Biden
running for president Democratic
candidate Kamala Harris said come on in
the water is warm that's what she said
yeah that's the true quote that's what
she said yeah then Bernie Sanders said
that's because I may have peed in it
I'm working on my Bernie Sanders he's
always going stick elating it's a subtle
impression I'm working I'm working hard
on it was reported today that that Joe
Biden is leading Joe Biden is leading
Bernie Sanders by eight points yeah yeah
no no not it not on the polls in their
weekly game of shuffleboard
some some Democrats don't like Joe Biden
but of all the current possibilities he
has the best chance of beating Donald
Trump yeah question to being gone well
coming in second heart disease yep there
I think it's diabetes there's a long
list anyway